gop senators are headed to the white
house they're trying to negotiate
president biden's coronavirus relief
package
and make some changes that they want to
see republicans have offered a 600
billion dollar package much less than
the 1.9 trillion dollar package from the
white house
key differences include cutting stimulus
checks from fourteen hundred dollars to
a thousand dollars
and only sending them to people in lower
income brackets
we are very targeted we're targeted to
the needs of the american people
treating our tax dollars as if there are
tax dollars not just money to spend
the risk is not that it is uh too big
this package the risk
is that it is too small and that remains
his view and one he'll certainly express
today both the white house plan and the
gop counter proposal set aside 160
billion dollars to increase covid
vaccination distribution
the testing and ppe supplies the white
house also wants fema to open 100 new
vaccination sites nationwide by
february